From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt, sitting in for Ira Glass. Family group chat, created May 19, 2023, two years ago, before. Yousef Hammash-- "Send this link to Aseel, Salsabil, and Heba so they can enter the group." Manal-- "We are all gathered together. What a blessing." Heart emoji. "I don't have Hasan or Ahmed. Yousef must add them." "I sent the link above, you idiots, so you can send it to them." Yousef reshares link. "Send them the link." "I sent it."
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目。我是Chana Joffe-Walt，代替Ira Glass主持。家庭群聊，创建于2023年5月19日，那是两年前，在此之前。Yousef Hammash——“把这个链接发给Aseel、Salsabil和Heba，这样她们就能进群了。”Manal——“我们都在一起呢。真是太幸福了。”（爱心表情）“我没有Hasan或Ahmed的账号。Yousef得把他们加进来。”“我刚才把链接发上去了，你们这些笨蛋，自己发给他们就行了。”Yousef重新分享了链接。“把链接发给他们。”“我发了。”
Manal-- "We want to go out tomorrow, to the beach." "OK, why is the group called the shitty family?" "Yeah. Who's the son of a gun who names the group?" Laughing emoji. "Please. Isn't this Yousef's doing?" "It's Yousef." "I did it for your sake, sister." "God bless you, pride of the Arabs."
Manal——“我们明天想出去玩，去海滩。”“好吧，为什么群名叫做‘破烂家庭’？”“对啊。是谁这么缺德给群起这个名字？”（笑脸表情）“拜托。这难道不是Yousef干的吗？”“就是Yousef。”“我是为了你们好，妹妹。”“上帝保佑你，阿拉伯人的骄傲。”
"Manal wants to invite us to the beach, Hadeel." "I want to take you to the beach." "When?" "We're thinking either tomorrow or Monday." "I will let my children go. But what day?" "We're thinking Monday." "We need a watermelon. That's the most important thing." "You're making conditions as well?" "The watermelon is more important than you." "I'm being mocked." Yousef-- "Whoever wants to go with us, like this message. I will set up a time later." "Where?" "To the beach." "But what day?" "Tomorrow." Clown face.
“Manal想邀请我们去海滩，Hadeel。”“我想带你们去海滩。”“什么时候？”“我们在考虑明天或者周一。”“我会让我孩子们去的。但具体哪天？”“我们在考虑周一。”“我们需要个西瓜。这是最重要的事。”“你也要提条件？”“西瓜比你重要多了。”“我被嘲笑了。”Yousef——“谁想跟我们一起去，就点赞这条消息。我稍后定个时间。”“去哪？”“去海滩。”“但哪天？”“明天。”（小丑表情）
Yousef, who started this group chat for his family, he's been on our show before, Yousef Hammash. He was a humanitarian aid worker in Gaza, grew up there, lived there his whole life. He started this group chat with his family months before the war, before October 7, when Hamas attacked Southern Israel. After that, Yousef became responsible for moving his whole family-- his four sisters, their extended families-- from one place to another, trying to escape Israel's bombing.
Yousef，这个家庭群聊的创建者，他以前上过我们的节目，他叫Yousef Hammash。他曾在加沙做人道主义援助工作，在那里长大，住了一辈子。他在战争前几个月，也就是10月7日哈马斯袭击以色列南部之前，创建了这个家庭群聊。那之后，Yousef担负起了转移全家人的重任——他的四个姐妹和她们的大家庭——从一个地方转移到另一个地方，试图躲避以色列的轰炸。
After six months of displacement and near-death experiences and worrying for his children, Yousef did something he thought he'd never do-- he left Gaza. This was last spring. He went with his wife, mother, and his kids to Egypt. His sisters decided to stay behind. And since that time, almost no one has been able to leave Gaza. That was a little more than a year ago. The group chat is still going.
在经历了六个月的流离失所、濒临死亡的经历以及为孩子担忧之后，Yousef做了一件他以为自己永远不会做的事——他离开了加沙。那是去年春天。他带着妻子、母亲和孩子们去了埃及。他的姐妹们决定留下来。从那时起，几乎没人能离开加沙。那已经是大约一年多前的事了。这个群聊依然活跃。
What are they talking about in the WhatsApp group?
他们在WhatsApp群里都在聊些什么？
I don't know. Daily life, complaining, or making fun.
我不知道。日常琐事、抱怨，或者互相调侃。
Uh-huh.
嗯。
Sending-- I don't know. Sometimes it's jokes. Sometimes they're crying. It depends. Voice, text, photos, everything.
发送……我不知道。有时是笑话。有时是哭诉。看情况。语音、文字、照片，什么都有。
OK.
好的。
Just--
只是……
OK.
好的。
--this is like the refuge for them, where they go. And more, the sisters are talking. And my mother-- and we just observe.
……这就是他们的避风港，他们去的地方。而且更多时候是姐妹们在聊。还有我母亲——我们只是旁观。
"We," meaning the people who are outside Gaza now-- Yousef, his wife, his kids, and his mom. Inside Gaza, the sisters make plans, talk about who they ran into that day, share pictures of their kids, of bombings. They send voice memos to each other to share news and cheer each other up.
“我们”指的是现在在加沙之外的人——Yousef、他的妻子、孩子和母亲。在加沙内部，姐妹们制定计划，聊起那天遇到了谁，分享孩子的照片，还有被轰炸的场景。她们互相发送语音备忘录，分享新闻，互相打气。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
Hadeel, my sister is feeling down. Come here, Hadeel. Let's go out. Let's go somewhere. I'm buying. I have Ahmed's money. My sister is feeling low, so let's do something fun.
Hadeel，我妹妹心情不好。过来，Hadeel。我们出去走走吧。去哪儿都行。我请客。我有Ahmed的钱。我妹妹心情低落，我们得做点开心的事。
In the year-plus since Yousef has left, the sisters have all moved again. They're not all together anymore. And they keep moving. They've survived airstrikes, illnesses, months with no food at all coming in. And they keep checking in, here, in the chat.
在Yousef离开的一年多里，姐妹们又搬迁了。她们不再住在一起了。她们一直在奔波。她们在空袭、疾病和长达数月没有粮食供应的情况下幸存了下来。她们一直在这里，在群聊里互相报平安。
Yousef, the problem-solver in the family, the "don't worry, I'll take care of it" guy, he keeps trying to figure out how to solve the same problems over and over. When his sister, Aseel, texts, "If I clean, I get dizzy. If I cook, I get dizzy. There's no edible food. It's worse than you can imagine," Yousef replies, "Buy anything."
Yousef，家里的“解决问题专家”，那个总说“别担心，我来搞定”的人，他一直在反复寻找解决同样问题的方法。当他的妹妹Aseel发消息说：“我一打扫卫生就头晕。一做饭也头晕。根本没东西吃。情况比你想象的还要糟。”Yousef回复说：“什么都行，买吧。”
Aseel-- "Don't worry about me, love. All is OK." Then they go back and forth. Aseel-- "1 kilo of rice is 35." Yousef-- "No problem. I'll pay." Aseel-- "A kilo of flour is 50." Yousef-- "Whatever the price." Aseel-- "The issue is not the price. It's the cash." Yousef-- "I don't know what one can do." Aseel-- "The situation has become very bad." Yousef-- "The problem is, I can't do anything."
Aseel——“别担心我，亲爱的。一切都好。”然后他们一来一回地聊天。Aseel——“1公斤大米要35块。”Yousef——“没问题。我来付。”Aseel——“1公斤面粉要50块。”Yousef——“不管多少钱。”Aseel——“问题不在钱，是现金。”Yousef——“我不知道还能做什么。”Aseel——“情况变得非常糟糕。”Yousef——“问题是，我什么都做不了。”
Even your money doesn't help you.
哪怕有钱也帮不上忙。
You can't find food even if you have money.
就算你有钱，你也找不到食物。
Exactly. And if it's available, it's very, very expensive. But mostly, you cannot find it.
没错。如果能买到，也贵得离谱。但大多时候，根本找不到。
What's it like for you to talk to Aseel?
和Aseel聊天对你来说是什么样的体验？
Yeah, I was talking to her today. But it's just actually-- I feel useless. Her daughter is crying, which-- a year old. She's crying because there is no bread. There is nothing she can feed her. Even all what I can do, being outside now, all what I can do is send money or just secure money. But it's not enough anymore.
是的，我今天刚跟她聊过。但实际上……我感到很无力。她女儿在哭，才一岁大。她哭是因为没有面包。没有东西喂她。即便我人在外面，能做的也只是汇钱或者搞到钱。但这已经不够了。
Yousef spent the first six months of the war experiencing everything his family is experiencing together. And when he left, it felt inconceivable that it could go on this way, this much longer. But it has. His phone keeps getting new messages. And he keeps reassuring and responding and arranging and trying to provide comfort.
Yousef在战争的前六个月里，和家人一起经历了所有的苦难。当他离开时，他认为这种情况不可能持续这么久。但它确实持续了。他的手机不断收到新的消息。他依然在安慰、回复、安排，试图给予家人慰藉。
And then, these last few weeks, being unable anymore, even with all his skills and connections, to get money, cash into his sister's hands, hearing how their children are not eating, something changed for Yousef. He felt literally dumbstruck.
然后，在这最后几周，即使拥有所有的能力和人脉，也无法将现金送到姐妹手中，听到孩子们吃不上饭，Yousef发生了一些变化。他简直感到麻木。
Even words are not helpful anymore because they are finished. And I used all the words. And I think I need to start to find other languages. But I hope it's going to be fine. It's going to be a matter of days, hopefully. All what I can do is just to be supportive.
甚至语言都已经失效了，因为它们被用尽了。我用尽了所有的词汇。我想我得找点别的表达方式。但我希望一切会好起来。希望这只是几天的事。我所能做的只是给予支持。
Do you still say those things?
你还会说那些话吗？
It's useless anymore. Just even saying them became something stupid. I don't know what to say, to be honest. And OK, in Arabic language, we have [SPEAKING ARABIC] any other God against them. All these words became useless. Even these words that we were using all of our life to calm each other became meaningless because even using it became unfair. It's really painful when you communicate with anyone from Gaza. It's really, really painful.
没用了。甚至再说这些话都显得很蠢。老实说，我不知道该说什么。好吧，在阿拉伯语里，我们有（阿拉伯语），反对他们的神之类的。所有这些词都变得毫无意义。甚至我们一生用来安慰彼此的话语也变得毫无意义，因为使用它们本身就不公平。当你和加沙的任何人交流时，真的非常痛苦。真的，非常痛苦。
Does it make you want to avoid it?
这会让你想逃避吗？
100%.
百分之百。
Yeah.
是的。
Otherwise, I wouldn't stay sane. I would lose my mind.
否则，我无法保持理智。我会疯掉的。
Leaving Gaza made Yousef the newest member of a well-established club. There are about 5 million Palestinians living inside the West Bank in Gaza. And the rest, about 9 million Palestinians live all over the world, people who are trying to maintain family and connections across countries and time zones and bad cell connections.
离开加沙让Yousef成为了一个庞大群体的新成员。约有500万巴勒斯坦人生活在约旦河西岸和加沙。其余约900万巴勒斯坦人散布在世界各地，人们试图跨越国界、时区和糟糕的网络信号来维系家庭和联系。
Today's show is about those conversations, inside one family and between friends, colleagues. Yousef's family agreed to share all the messages they sent back and forth to each other over years. We got them translated-- all the late night musings and updates and petty resentments and serious resentments and jokes and plans and fears, intimate moments, where you can see how these conversations and relationships change over time.
今天的节目就是关于这些对话，发生在一个家庭内部，以及朋友和同事之间。Yousef的家人同意分享他们多年来发送的所有聊天记录。我们把它们翻译了出来——所有的深夜思绪、近况更新、琐碎的怨恨、严重的隔阂、笑话、计划、恐惧，还有那些私密的时刻，让你看到这些对话和关系是如何随着时间推移而改变的。
How do you keep being a family? And we hear from other people on the outside and others inside, figuring out what to say and what to keep secret. Stay with us.
你如何维系一个家庭？我们将听到来自外面的人和里面的人的声音，去了解他们是如何斟酌言辞，或者选择隐瞒什么的。请继续收听。
It's This American Life. Act One, I'm Fine. Don't Worry. Within any family, there's the group chat, and there's the side chat. The person Yousef is always checking in with most is his youngest sister in Gaza, Aseel.
这里是《美国生活》。第一幕，我很好，别担心。在任何家庭中，都有群聊，也有私聊。Yousef总是最关注他在加沙的小妹妹Aseel。
June 2024, Yousef to Aseel-- "Yo, my sister, please confirm you're well." Aseel-- "I feel like I haven't seen you since the last century." The thing Yousef says more than anything else in these chats is, "Please confirm you're well." The thing Aseel says most? "I'm fine. Don't worry."
2024年6月，Yousef对Aseel说——“嘿，妹妹，请确认你平安。”Aseel——“感觉好像上个世纪没见你了。”Yousef在这些聊天记录里说得最多的一句话就是：“请确认你平安。”而Aseel说得最多的是什么？“我很好，别担心。”
Yousef says Aseel is the one in the family who's the most like him, practical, can-do, unfazed, also stubborn. Aseel is 10 years younger than Yousef. She's a nurse. She wants to know things and do things.
Yousef说Aseel是家里最像他的人，务实、行动力强、沉着冷静，还有点固执。Aseel比Yousef小10岁。她是一名护士。她喜欢探究，喜欢做事。
She's young, but she's expert. Usually, Aseel is the most-- between my sister, I look to Aseel as the most wise.
她年轻但专业。通常，Aseel是……在我的姐妹们中，我觉得Aseel是最聪明的。
She looks to him the same way. She trusts him. When Aseel was trying to figure out the safest place to give birth to her first child in a war zone, the person she planned it out with was Yousef. When she needs advice on anything, Yousef.
她也同样仰赖他。她信任他。当Aseel试图在战区寻找最安全的地方生下第一个孩子时，她计划商量的人就是Yousef。无论她需要什么建议，都会找Yousef。
In the beginning of their WhatsApp chat after he left Gaza, you can see Yousef trying to set the terms of their new situation. His point over and over-- the important things have not changed. I'll call every day. Anything you need, I'm here. Yousef-- "If you want anything, whatever it is, do not hesitate."
在他离开加沙后的WhatsApp聊天初期，你可以看到Yousef试图为他们的新处境定下基调。他反复强调的一点是——重要的事情没有改变。我会每天打电话。你需要什么，我都在。Yousef——“如果你想要什么，不管是什么，别犹豫。”
Aseel jokes, "After all, everything is cheap." Yousef-- "Live and spend." Aseel-- "My dear brother, I swear I want nothing but to see you. I swear I don't need anything." Yousef-- "This is my duty, my sister. Just take care of yourself." Aseel responds with a voice memo-- her and her baby, Seela.
Aseel开玩笑道：“反正什么都便宜。”Yousef——“活着，花吧。”Aseel——“亲爱的哥哥，我发誓我除了见到你什么都不想要。我发誓我什么都不缺。”Yousef——“这是我的责任，妹妹。照顾好你自己就行。”Aseel回复了一条语音备忘录——是她和孩子Seela的声音。
[ASEEL SPEAKING GIBBERISH, SEELA GIGGLING]
[Aseel说着胡话，Seela咯咯笑]
24 hours later, Yousef, seemingly concerned that he didn't get his point across, writes, "The most important thing is that you do not lack anything. Buy whatever you want."
24小时后，Yousef似乎担心自己没表达清楚，写道：“最重要的是你不能缺任何东西。买任何你想要的。”
Relationships shift all the time, sometimes suddenly, but the long, slow changes, they can be just as dramatic. Yousef and Aseel lived within walking distance their whole lives. They saw each other in person all the time. They shared life, a landscape. And right away, within a week of leaving Gaza, Yousef realized how much information he gathered just by being there, seeing Aseel face to face, seeing what she needed. When he wasn't there, he understood, oh, Aseel isn't great at asking for things.
人际关系总是不断变化，有时是突然的，但漫长而缓慢的变化同样具有戏剧性。Yousef和Aseel一生都住得步行可达。他们一直面对面相处。他们共享生活，共享一片土地。离开加沙不到一周，Yousef就意识到他通过身临其境、面对面地看到Aseel需要什么，获得了多少信息。当他不在身边时，他才明白，噢，Aseel不擅长开口要东西。
It's something I really like about her, how decent she is, and she will never ask for anything. But at the same time, I'm not there to understand her needs anymore. And my other sister called me. She lost her phone. And she's like, OK, buy me a phone. Send it to anyone to Gaza. Yeah, OK, I'll do it. Aseel will never do that. And that's my issue with her.
这是我非常喜欢她的一点，她有多么得体，她永远不会要求任何东西。但与此同时，我不在身边，再也无法理解她的需求了。我另一个姐妹给我打电话，她弄丢了手机。她说，好吧，给我买个手机。寄给加沙的任何人。好吧，我会买。但Aseel永远不会这么做。这就是我和她之间的问题。
So every time Aseel says, I'm fine, Yousef has to guess what he can do to help. Four months after he left Gaza, Yousef was reading and hearing about bombing. Increasingly, the bombing was where she was living. The other sisters were moving. Yousef figured Aseel would, too, and made a plan for her to move to a safer area called Al Mawasi, just like he always did. He would pay for it, of course.
所以每次Aseel说她很好时，Yousef都得去猜他能做些什么来帮忙。他离开加沙四个月后，Yousef一直在读新闻、听关于轰炸的消息。轰炸范围越来越靠近她居住的地方。其他姐妹们一直在搬家。Yousef觉得Aseel也应该搬，于是像往常一样为她规划好去一个叫Al Mawasi的安全区域。当然，费用由他承担。
Yousef to Aseel-- "There's a furnished apartment in this project, $1,000 per month." Aseel-- "Oh, my God, it's a lot. I don't know if the war will go on longer or not. The amount of money is a lot." Yousef-- "Call her. You will love it." The next day, Yousef-- "Have you seen the apartment? It's a good place." Aseel-- "It's forbidden to be extravagant. I didn't go, no."
Yousef对Aseel说——“这个项目里有一套带家具的公寓，每月1000美元。”Aseel——“噢，天哪，太贵了。我不知道战争会不会持续更久。这笔钱太多了。”Yousef——“去看看吧。你会喜欢的。”第二天，Yousef——“你去看过那套公寓了吗？是个好地方。”Aseel——“铺张浪费是不被允许的。我没去，没有。”
Four hours later, Aseel-- "It's really nice, honestly. But it's expensive." Yousef-- "Is it a suitable place??" Double question mark. Aseel-- "I'm fine now. If there's an evacuation, I will leave." She did not move to the apartment.
四小时后，Aseel——“说实话，真的很不错。但太贵了。”Yousef——“是个合适的地方吗？？”（双问号）Aseel——“我现在很好。如果有疏散令，我会离开的。”她没有搬进那套公寓。
Money was becoming an issue between them in a new way. Yousef had always supported a lot of people in the family, but after he left Gaza, he started doing it through Aseel. She'd tell Yousef who among their family and friends in Gaza needed help. Here's how much. Here's a list. He'd coordinate with her to get the money to them. Aseel to Yousef-- "Everyone thinks I'm the finance ministry." Yousef-- "Let them think that."
钱在他们之间以一种新的方式成为了问题。Yousef一直资助家里很多人，但他离开加沙后，开始通过Aseel来完成。她会告诉Yousef亲戚朋友中谁需要帮助，金额多少，列个清单。他会和她协调把钱送给他们。Aseel对Yousef说——“大家都以为我是财务部部长。”Yousef——“让他们以为吧。”
This meant, now, Aseel knew how much money Yousef was giving out, how many people he was supporting in Gaza, not to mention trying to find a place for his family on the outside. Aseel didn't want to add to the burden. Aseel-- "Don't worry about me, love. You're going to have travel expenses and expenses that will destroy even mountains. Don't send me money until you guys get settled and organize your matters." Yousef-- "Don't worry. Your brother is strong as a whale."
这意味着，现在Aseel知道Yousef拿出了多少钱，他在加沙资助了多少人，更不用说他在外面还要想办法安置自己的家人。Aseel不想增加他的负担。Aseel——“别担心我，亲爱的。你会有旅行费用，还有那些能压垮大山的开支。在我们安定下来之前别再给我寄钱了。”Yousef——“别担心。你的哥哥像鲸鱼一样强壮。”
As the months passed, Aseel continued to lean on Yousef for some things, but she also quietly started trying to manage more things on her own. In August, a few months after Yousef left, Aseel's baby was suffering from a terrible rash. She couldn't figure out how to treat it. She couldn't find the cream she needed. Aseel sent me pictures to see if I had any ideas. But she didn't tell Yousef, even though Yousef knows all sorts of medical people in Gaza.
随着时间流逝，Aseel继续在某些事情上依靠Yousef，但她也开始悄悄尝试独自处理更多事情。8月，Yousef离开几个月后，Aseel的孩子得了严重的皮疹。她不知道怎么治。找不到需要的药膏。Aseel给我发了照片看我有没有头绪。但她没告诉Yousef，尽管Yousef认识加沙各种医疗工作者。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
No, but it's just one thing that I'm hiding. No, there's a new disease that has spread targeting children, which is-- I don't know-- an allergy. It's a skin rash or something like that. So I don't know how to treat her. And every time I use something, it spreads even more.
不，这只是我隐瞒的一件事。有一种新的疾病在儿童中传播，我不知道是什么，是一种过敏。皮疹之类的东西。我不知道怎么治疗。每次我用点东西，它反而蔓延得更厉害。
Why wouldn't you tell him about the skin problem?
为什么不告诉他皮肤问题？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
Because he would be upset. In reality, they're not here, so he won't know what to do. He'll feel like it's his dereliction of duty. Like, he could have done something. I don't want him to feel that way.
因为他会难过的。事实上，他们不在这儿，所以他不知道该怎么办。他会觉得自己失职了。好像他本可以做点什么。我不想让他有这种感觉。
But couldn't Yousef help you get access to the medicine?
但Yousef不能帮你搞到药吗？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
Yes, but he'll send his friends to look. And in reality, I looked a lot, and I couldn't find anything. So I don't know what the solution is. [SIGHS] I don't want them to be worried over there because I can solve this. As long as I can solve this, there's no need to let them worry, and no need to tell them.
是的，但他会派朋友去找。但实际上，我找了很多遍，什么都找不到。所以我不知道解决办法是什么。（叹气）我不希望他们在远方担心，因为我自己能解决。只要我能解决，就没必要让他们担心，也没必要告诉他们。
Keeping things from each other-- this became a bigger part of their relationship. Yousef was traveling around-- Egypt, England-- trying to get asylum somewhere in the world.
向对方隐瞒事情，成了他们关系中很大的一部分。Yousef一直在到处奔波——埃及、英国——试图在世界某个地方寻求庇护。
He told Aseel about some of it, and he edited out stuff that would be too sharp a contrast to Aseel's life. He'd share a selfie from the train, but he would not tell her about taking the kids to see the pyramids, the Nile. He'd gleefully tell her he's near where David Beckham lives, but he wouldn't mention the restaurant he went to that day.
他告诉了Aseel其中一部分情况，但也删减了那些与Aseel生活对比太强烈的细节。他会分享一张在火车上的自拍，但不会告诉她带孩子去看金字塔、看尼罗河的事。他会兴高采烈地告诉她他在David Beckham家附近，但不会提到他那天去的餐厅。
Aseel knew he was keeping stuff from her, and in the texts, she's constantly nudging him to send her pictures and updates. And when he does share something, she responds quickly with hearts and says things like, "I am happy just seeing your pictures. It's amazing, bro."
Aseel知道他在隐瞒，在短信里，她不断催促他发照片和近况。当他真的分享了什么，她会很快用爱心表情回复，说些：“能看到你的照片我就很开心了。太棒了，哥哥。”
Yousef sends a picture of himself on a bike in London. Aseel-- "Wow." Smiley face. "It's amazing-- and an athlete." Smiley face, heart. Another time, a selfie of Yousef in Cairo. Aseel-- "Advice for you--" smiley face, heart, "--this haircut looks good on you."
Yousef发了一张他在伦敦骑自行车的照片。Aseel——“哇。”（笑脸）“太棒了——还是个运动员。”（笑脸、爱心）还有一次，Yousef在开罗的自拍。Aseel——“给你个建议——”（笑脸、爱心）“这个发型很适合你。”
Aseel had pushed Yousef to leave Gaza. She considered going with him, but the cost was enormous, more than Yousef could cover. And she didn't want to leave her in-laws and extended family behind in Gaza. She's genuinely very happy for Yousef, but there's also a new, unfamiliar feeling.
Aseel曾催促Yousef离开加沙。她考虑过跟他走，但成本巨大，超过了Yousef的承受能力。而且她不想丢下夫家和大家族留在加沙。她真心为Yousef感到高兴，但心中也有一种新的、陌生的感觉。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
Whenever something happens that upsets me, I blame him for not being here. I don't say that to him, but internally, I blame him. You were not supposed to leave. You were supposed to stay here. It's like a psychological war between me and myself.
每当发生什么事让我心烦，我就会怪他没在这儿。我没对他说，但在心里，我怪他。你不应该离开的。你应该留在这儿的。这就像是我和自己之间的一场心理战。
Yousef knows it without her saying it because he feels it, too.
Yousef不用她说也知道，因为他自己也有同感。
Always, I keep saying, I should have taken my sisters out with me. I shouldn't have listened to any objections. Despite that they couldn't do it, they have their children, I should have tried more. I was--
我总是说，我应该把姐妹们一起带出来的。我不该听任何反对意见。尽管她们做不到，她们有孩子，但我本应该更努力的。我当时——
How often are you thinking about that, Yousef?
你多久会想一次这个，Yousef？
Whenever I have a call with any of them.
只要我和她们中任何一个人通话时。
Every time you talk to them?
每次你和她们聊天时？
Whenever something happens, the first thing that came to my head-- I should have taken everyone.
每当发生什么事，我脑子里闪过的第一件事就是——我本应该把所有人都带出来的。
One of the reasons Aseel didn't leave Gaza with Yousef is she thought the war would end soon. Another reason-- she wanted to go home, to the north, where her house is, in Jabalia. She wanted to raise her daughter at home. She thought about it every day. She was waiting and waiting for the Israeli military to allow residents of the north to return. These months and months of text messages really convey just how long she was stuck.
Aseel没有和Yousef离开加沙的原因之一是她以为战争很快会结束。另一个原因是——她想回家，回到北部的Jabalia。她想在家里抚养女儿。她每天都在想这件事。她在等待，等待以色列军队允许北部居民返回。这几个月来的短信记录真正展现了她被困了多久。
You can see Aseel getting ground down over time. There's no electricity, no clean water. She keeps getting sick. There's bombings and drones and just uncertainty, endless uncertainty. September 2024, Aseel-- "Oh, by God, we are tired. I wish I had listened to you and gone with you." October, Aseel-- "Officially, I swear to God that I cannot bear the situation at all."
你可以看到Aseel随着时间流逝而逐渐崩溃。没有电，没有干净的水。她不断生病。到处是轰炸、无人机和无尽的不确定性。2024年9月，Aseel——“噢，上帝，我们累了。真希望当时听你的，跟你一起走了。”10月，Aseel——“正式声明，我发誓我真的完全无法承受这种情况了。”
November, Aseel-- "Seela has malnutrition." Yousef-- "Oh, my God. What did the doctor tell you?" Aseel-- "She told me she has malnutrition, and she's very underweight and needs vitamins. I don't know what to feed her. I didn't feed her canned food because I was afraid she'd get sick. Today is the first time I regret giving birth." Yousef-- "May God help you, sister." January 2025, voice memo from Aseel to the group chat.
11月，Aseel——“Seela营养不良。”Yousef——“噢，天哪。医生怎么说？”Aseel——“她告诉我她营养不良，体重太轻，需要补充维生素。我不知道喂她什么。我没喂她罐头食品，怕她生病。今天是我第一次后悔生孩子。”Yousef——“上帝保佑你，妹妹。”2025年1月，Aseel发给群聊的语音备忘录。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Happy New Year.
[非英语语音] 新年快乐。
Oh, I forgot to say, Happy New Year. I hope that next year-- no, no, this year-- yes, this year, we see you all. I hope you'll be looking forward to seeing us. And we'll be looking forward to seeing you. And Happy New Year. That's it.
噢，我忘了说，新年快乐。我希望明年——不，不，今年——是的，今年，我们能见到你们所有人。我希望你们期待见到我们。我们也会期待见到你们。新年快乐。就这样。
Then, January 15, some news. Hammash family group chat, Aseel-- "The president of Qatar wants to announce a ceasefire soon." "Oh, God." "Get excited, guys." "The war is over." "It's a truce. It's a truce. It's over." "Oh, God, a truce." "Thank God."
接着，1月15日，传出消息。Hammash家庭群，Aseel——“卡塔尔总统很快要宣布停火了。”“噢，上帝。”“大家振作起来。”“战争结束了。”“是休战。是休战。结束了。”“噢，上帝，休战。”“感谢上帝。”
The moment Israel and Hamas agreed to a ceasefire last January, Aseel began planning her return to the north, to her house. It was time, the thing she'd been waiting for. But Yousef was against it. Yousef to Aseel-- "In my opinion, sister, you should stay where you are. It's early, my sister. And I hear strange things in the north."
当以色列和哈马斯去年1月达成停火协议时，Aseel开始计划回到北部，回到她的家。时候到了，这是她一直等待的事情。但Yousef反对。Yousef对Aseel——“依我看，妹妹，你应该留在原地。太早了，妹妹。我在北部听到了一些奇怪的消息。”
Aseel-- "But I'm tired. How long will we continue like this?" Yousef-- "One by one, everything will be solved." Aseel-- "But man, the house is important." Yousef-- "Leave it to me. The war just stopped yesterday." Their other sisters were fine to wait and see, but Aseel kept pressing to go north. Yousef had access to satellite images, and his assessment was if Aseel went north, she'd find that she had no house anymore.
Aseel——“但我累了。我们还要这样多久？”Yousef——“一切都会慢慢解决的。”Aseel——“但是哥，家很重要。”Yousef——“交给我。战争昨天才刚刚停火。”其他姐妹对此持观望态度，但Aseel一再坚持要去北部。Yousef能看到卫星图像，他的评估是，如果Aseel去了北部，她会发现那里已经没有家了。
I don't think any house in that area is still standing. I'm trying not to be negative with everyone. Like, no, everything is leveled. But I know it's not there. So--
我觉得那片区域没有房子还是立着的。我尽量不在大家面前表现得太消极。就像，不，一切都被夷为平地了。但我知道房子已经不在了。所以——
You know for sure?
你确定吗？
The area where they live, it's not far from Kamal Adwan Hospital in the northern part of Gaza. And then recently, this military campaign was mainly in that area. And all of that area was leveled. And honestly, for the northern part of Gaza, where I am from and all my relatives, it's impossible that any house still standing there.
她们住的那片区域，离北部加沙的Kamal Adwan医院不远。最近的军事行动主要集中在那片区域。那一整片都被夷为平地。说实话，对于我出身以及所有亲戚所在的加沙北部，那儿不可能还有任何房子立着。
Yousef and Aseel's texts about this went on for weeks. Their back and forth reads like Yousef is still that older brother who's in control. But one of the things Aseel is not telling him, she and her husband, Ahmed, have already begun moving their things north. Yousef thinks he's still in a position to grant permission. Aseel tells him, it's already done.
Yousef和Aseel关于此事的短信往来了几周。他们的对话读起来就像Yousef还是那个掌控一切的哥哥。但Aseel没告诉他的一件事是，她和丈夫Ahmed已经开始把东西搬往北部了。Yousef以为他还能批准什么。Aseel告诉他，已经做了。
Yousef to Aseel-- "You can go for two days and try it, but try not to move your things." Aseel-- "Ahmed transferred 90% of them." Smiley face. She was already there.
Yousef对Aseel——“你可以去个两天试试，但尽量别搬你的东西。”Aseel——“Ahmed已经转运了90%了。”（笑脸）她已经在那里了。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
I came back because I know I belong to this place. I wanted to come back. I want to fix up my place and live in it. I want to have my inner calm back.
我回来是因为我知道我属于这里。我想回来。我想修好我的地方，住进去。我想找回内心的平静。
Is there anything there?
那里有什么吗？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
The house was blown out, and there were no walls. There were only the support pillars, the ceiling, and the floors. That's what was left. So I had to make a wall out of tarp. I covered the entire house with tarp, and I'm trying to adapt.
房子被炸毁了，没有墙。只剩下支撑柱、天花板和地板。这就是剩下的。所以我不得不拿防水布做了堵墙。我用防水布覆盖了整个房子，我在试着适应。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
What is around you? Are there buildings? And is there anything there?
你周围是什么情况？有建筑物吗？那儿还有别的东西吗？
I still have a bit of a roof over my head, but my neighbors next door set up a tent on top of the rubble of their house. And it's the same with the neighbors all the way down the street. Those whose houses are still standing, they fixed them, and they live in them now. Others set up tents on the rubble of their homes.
我的头上还有一点遮挡，但我隔壁的邻居在他们家废墟上搭了个帐篷。整条街上的邻居都是这样。房子还没倒的，他们修补了一下，现在住进去。其他人都在家园废墟上搭帐篷。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
What did Yousef think of you moving back to Jabalia?
Yousef怎么看你搬回Jabalia？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
Yousef didn't know I was moving back. He only knew I was coming to check on the place and belongings and then go back south. But then I moved back and let him deal with my decision. I shocked him with that. He didn't approve of me going back north.
Yousef不知道我搬回去了。他只知道我回来看看地方和财物，然后再回南部。但我搬回去了，让他去处理我的决定吧。我让他震惊了。他不赞成我回到北部。
OK. [CHUCKLES] And what did he say when he found out you were staying?
好的。（轻笑）当你告诉他你要留下时，他说了什么？
He told me to wait a bit, take more time, be careful with my decision, and blah, blah, blah. I told him no. I'm going to stay for a bit. I feel that I belong to this place, and I need to stay here.
他叫我再等等，多花点时间，对我的决定要谨慎，blablabla。我跟他说不。我要留一会儿。我觉得我属于这个地方，我需要留在这里。
Yousef saw that Aseel was not alone in this decision. As soon as people were allowed back, 376,000 Palestinians returned to their homes in the north. And they returned to places with no roads or schools or hospitals or clean water, and to homes that were damaged and destroyed. But they still went back.
Yousef看到不止Aseel一个人做了这个决定。一旦人们被允许返回，就有37.6万巴勒斯坦人回到了北部家园。他们回到的是没有道路、学校、医院或清洁水源的地方，回到的是受损和被摧毁的家。但他们依然回去了。
After weeks of pushing back, Yousef got it. It was easy to urge patience from the outside, but it was hard in the south, where they had been forced to live for more than a year. Towns in the south were overwhelmed by displaced people from the north. There was tension between people from the north and south. There was months and months of displacement. People were tired, degraded. It was better to be in a tent where your home was than in a tent in Rafah or Khan Younis.
在经历几周的劝阻后，Yousef明白了。从外面敦促耐心很容易，但在南部，在他们被迫居住了一年多的地方，这很难。南部城镇被北部流离失所的人挤满了。南北方人之间存在紧张关系。经历了几个月的流离失所。人们厌倦了，失去了尊严。在自己家园的地方待在帐篷里，总比在Rafah或Khan Younis的帐篷里要好。
Now that she was home, Aseel began trying to live, not just survive. Her husband, Ahmed, set up a solar panel and started a phone charging station, a small business. Aseel found a job with an NGO doing data entry. Yousef hadn't wanted her to work. He thought going outside was unsafe. But Aseel wanted to have money of her own. Yousef told me, despite his objections, he was proud seeing what Aseel had created.
既然回到家了，Aseel开始尝试去生活，而不只是生存。她的丈夫Ahmed架设了太阳能板，开了一家手机充电站，做点小生意。Aseel在一家NGO找到了一份数据录入的工作。Yousef不想让她工作。他认为在外面不安全。但Aseel想有自己的钱。Yousef告诉我，尽管他反对，但看到Aseel创造的东西，他很骄傲。
For two months, the ceasefire held. March 18, Hammash family group chat. "The war is back." "Damn." "God is sufficient for me, and He is the best disposer of affairs." 2:39 AM, Yousef writes, "Call Aseel. I can't get through." Seven hours later, Aseel-- "I'm fine. Don't worry."
停火维持了两个月。3月18日，Hammash家庭群。“战争又开始了。”“该死。”“真主足矣，他是最好的代理人。”凌晨2:39，Yousef写道：“给Aseel打电话。我打不通。”七小时后，Aseel——“我很好。别担心。”
Now that she was back north and the war was back on, all the little ways Aseel had been gathering herself over the last year-- making her own decisions, working for her own money, relying mostly on herself-- became essential for her survival. It's like she anticipated a time when, even with love and support from the outside, she was going to need to be entirely self-sufficient. That time was now.
既然她回到了北部，战争又恢复了，Aseel过去一年里逐渐建立起来的那些自我照顾方式——自己做决定，赚自己的钱，主要依靠自己——成了她生存的关键。就像她预料到会有这样一个时刻，即使有外面的爱与支持，她也需要完全自给自足。那个时刻就是现在。
When Israel violated the ceasefire in March, it launched one of the deadliest days of the war, 400 people killed in a single day in the north and also throughout the Gaza Strip. Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu said, this is only the beginning. Israel barred all food, aid, and any other supplies from coming into the territory, a complete ban that would end up lasting more than two months.
当以色列在3月破坏停火时，发动了战争中最致命的日子之一，北部以及整个加沙地带一天内有400人死亡。以色列总理内塔尼亚胡说，这仅仅是个开始。以色列禁止所有食物、援助和其他补给进入领土，这一全面禁令最终持续了两个多月。
What are you eating?
你们在吃什么？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
What's available is rice, lentils, tuna, sardines, and other canned food.
能吃到的有大米、扁豆、金枪鱼、沙丁鱼和其他罐头食品。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
For food, there's no flour. I ran out of flour a while ago. The flour in the market was not good for consumption because it was mixed with plaster by the sellers. May God guide them. There is a bombed house next to us. And there was flour under the rubble.
食物方面，没有面粉。我的面粉早就用完了。市场上的面粉因为被卖家混入了石膏，无法食用。上帝指引他们吧。我们隔壁有一栋被炸毁的房子。废墟下有面粉。
You dug through the rubble of your neighbor's house?
你翻了邻居家的废墟？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
Yes, that's correct.
是的，没错。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
We were confident there was flour because our neighbor told us there was flour in his home. He also told us that if we could get it, we should eat it.
我们确信那里有面粉，因为邻居告诉我们他家有面粉。他还说如果我们能弄到，就应该吃掉它。
Wow.
哇。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
We collaborated with the neighbors and got it out. I don't know if you can imagine it, but it used to be a five-story building, and now it's only half a story. The whole situation was like a drowning person who's clutching at a straw. We all hoped that we could get the flour out.
我们和邻居合作把它弄出来了。我不知道你能不能想象，那曾经是一栋五层建筑，现在只剩下半层。整个情况就像落水者抓住稻草一样。我们都希望把面粉弄出来。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
They didn't get all of it out. I think they got about two bags. And everyone ended up with a small bag. We took some of the flour and sifted it twice and ate it. There was sand and plaster in it, but we made it work.
他们没能把全部弄出来。我想大约弄到了两袋。每个人最后分到了一小袋。我们拿走了一些面粉，筛了两次，吃掉了。里面有沙子和石膏，但我们只能将就。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
The flour lasted two days. Aseel stopped working. She tried not to go out more than she needed to. There were evacuation orders for areas in the north in April, again in May, but also, orders in the south and some in the middle area of Gaza, and threats of a new Israeli ground invasion in the north and bombs. Aseel was coming back from visiting an injured relative in the hospital. She was almost home, and there was an explosion right where the car was going to drop her off. This was two weeks ago.
面粉吃了两天。Aseel停止了工作。她尽量不作必要以外的出门。4月、5月又出现了北部的撤离令，南部和加沙中部也有撤离令，北部还有以色列地面入侵和炸弹的威胁。Aseel从医院看望受伤亲戚回来。她快到家时，载她的车卸客的地方发生了一次爆炸。这是两周前的事。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
I couldn't understand what was happening. I didn't know where to go. Suddenly, children appeared, and they were covered in blood. People were running, carrying martyrs. It was very bizarre, to be honest. They were carrying the martyr on a donkey cart, but there was no donkey. People were pulling it. And I said to myself, look at what we've become. What brought us to this life?
我无法理解发生了什么。我不知道去哪儿。突然间，孩子们出现了，身上沾满鲜血。人们在奔跑，抬着殉道者。说实话，这太诡异了。他们用驴车抬着殉道者，但没有驴。人们在拉着它。我对自己说，看看我们变成了什么样。是什么把我们带到了这种生活？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
I don't want to evacuate. I don't want to leave. I feel comfortable where I am. And if I left, I'd be anxious all the time. It's better for me to stay in my house and maintain my dignity. And that's it.
我不想撤离。我不想离开。我觉得待在现在的地方很舒服。如果离开，我会一直焦虑。待在我的房子里维持尊严对我来说更好。就这样。
How long will you stay there?
你要在那里待多久？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
I don't want to leave. But if they bombed somewhere near me, that's when I would leave.
我不想离开。但如果他们轰炸了离我不远的地方，那时候我就会离开。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
Didn't that happen today? They bombed somewhere close to where you are.
今天不就发生了吗？他们轰炸了离你不远的地方。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
I meant something closer. Today's bombing was close, but there was still a street between us.
我指的是更近的地方。今天的轰炸是近，但中间还隔着一条街。
So they would have to bomb the street you are living on for you to leave?
所以他们必须轰炸你居住的那条街你才会离开？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
No, God forbid. No, no.
不，上帝保佑。不，不。
Are your sisters or Yousef or other people trying to convince you to leave?
你的姐妹们或Yousef或者其他人试图说服你离开吗？
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
Yes. He wasn't convinced, but I'm doing what I want. What's in the news is not like what's on the ground. They exaggerate in the news. I tell them the situation where I live still allows me to wait a bit longer in my house. They should listen to me and be patient.
是的。他没被说服，但我行我素。新闻里说的和实地情况不一样。他们在新闻里夸大其词。我告诉他们我住的地方还允许我再多待一会儿。他们应该听我的，保持耐心。
Did you tell Yousef you were going? Will you tell him about what happened today?
你告诉Yousef你要去了吗？你会告诉他今天发生的事吗？
Not yet.
还没。
Not yet. I will tell him. He'd be pretty mad, most probably. He won't be happy that I got out during this dangerous situation. He would tell me to not leave home in the first place or to go stay with my sisters. I've been telling him since yesterday that the situation where I am is good.
还没。我会告诉他的。他会非常生气的，很可能。他不会高兴我在这么危险的情况下还出去。他会告诉我当初就不该离开家，或者去和姐妹们住一起。我从昨天开始就一直在告诉他我所在的地方情况很好。
You can see in the chat when Aseel does tell him. And she's right. He pleads with her to leave, to go to her sisters, who are sheltering in Gaza City. But she doesn't want to leave. In her home, she managed to collect bedding, some furniture, a small generator, toys for the baby, the beginnings of something livable. If they leave, everything could be gone when they get back. And, Aseel tells Yousef, nowhere is safe.
在聊天记录里可以看到Aseel什么时候告诉他。她是对的。他恳求她离开，去和在加沙城避难的姐妹们住一起。但她不想离开。在她的家里，她设法收集了寝具、一些家具、一台小发电机、婴儿玩具，一点点可生活的东西。如果离开，等回来时一切可能就都没了。而且，Aseel告诉Yousef，哪里都不安全。
May 15, 2:25 PM, Aseel-- "I'm fine, my love. Don't worry." Yousef-- "God is sufficient for us, and He is the best disposer of affairs, my sister." By midnight that night, more bombs. Hammash family group chat. "Can someone check on Aseel?" Manal-- "Yousef is talking to her."
5月15日，下午2:25，Aseel——“我很好，亲爱的。别担心。”Yousef——“真主足矣，他是我们最好的代理人，妹妹。”那天午夜前，更多炸弹。Hammash家庭群。“有人能确认下Aseel吗？”Manal——“Yousef正在跟她通话。”
Yeah, no, I don't know. She was refusing to leave yesterday. And then it became night. Then, OK, it wasn't safe to move. So I said, OK, let's see until tomorrow. Then, in the night, everything changed.
是啊，我不知道。她昨天拒绝离开。然后天黑了。然后，好吧，移动不安全了。所以我说，好吧，看明天的情况。然后，在深夜，一切都变了。
1:39 AM, Yousef-- "Please confirm you're well." Aseel-- "Thank God for everything."
凌晨1:39，Yousef——“请确认你平安。”Aseel——“感谢上帝保佑一切。”
We were chatting, texting each other.
我们当时在聊天，互相发信息。
1:59 AM, Yousef-- "May God keep you safe, my dear." Aseel-- "Thank God. I'm fine. Don't worry."
凌晨1:59，Yousef——“愿上帝保佑你平安，亲爱的。”Aseel——“感谢上帝。我很好。别担心。”
Last message at 2:00 AM, "Inshallah, everything is fine, and we'll meet soon," exchanging nice messages. Then at 3:15, she texted me, "I cannot breathe. I cannot see anything." And she sent this video.
凌晨2:00最后一条消息，“真主保佑，一切都会好，我们很快会见面，”交换了温馨的信息。然后在3:15，她发信息给我，“我无法呼吸。我什么都看不见。”然后她发了这个视频。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
In the video, the camera is pointed at what looks like a pile of rubble, but it's hard to see because it's dark, and they're surrounded by a cloud of dust and debris. In the upper corner of the video, there's a piece of drywall, maybe a fallen ceiling. Aseel is saying, I can't see a thing, calling for her husband, Ahmed. Someone says, Ahmed is there. He's there. Aseel says, I hope they don't bomb again.
在视频中，镜头对着看起来像是一堆废墟的地方，但很难看清因为太黑了，而且他们被尘土和碎片包围。视频上角有一块干墙，也许是掉下来的天花板。Aseel说，我什么都看不见，喊着她丈夫Ahmed。有人说，Ahmed在那儿。他在那儿。Aseel说，希望他们别再轰炸了。
Ahmed!
Ahmed！
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
And then--
然后——
I panic, and I keep calling. No phone calls. Waking up Heda, Hadil, trying to call there or call Ala so we can call her husband. She texted 3:18 AM, "They bombed the house next to my house. It's full of dead bodies. Most of the house collapsed. Everything collapsed on us. Pray for us." And she asked, pray for us that this night pass. And then she didn't respond. Yeah.
我惊慌失措，一直拨打电话。没法通话。叫醒Heda，Hadil，试图打过去或打给Ala以便联系她丈夫。她在凌晨3:18发了短信，“他们轰炸了我隔壁的房子。满地都是尸体。房子大部分坍塌了。一切都压在我们身上。为我们祈祷。”她还问，为我们祈祷能熬过今晚。然后她就没回应了。是啊。
I got messages from Aseel that night, too. She wrote, "I hope to stay alive until the morning. This is the hardest night since the beginning of the war. I'm so scared." And she wrote, "I feel like I won't meet my family again."
那天晚上我也收到了Aseel的消息。她写道，“我希望能熬到早上。这是战争开始以来最艰难的一晚。我太害怕了。”她写道，“我觉得我再也见不到家人了。”
Did she sound different to you than she has sounded at other scary moments?
她在其他可怕时刻的声音听起来和现在不一样吗？
Yeah. It's not the first time that they go through this. They go through it a lot, and she never reach out. When she know that nothing I can do, I'm outside, especially at 3:00 AM, it's quite serious. She always tried to spare me when this is-- it was serious. She's not just scared. She was about to die.
是的。这不是她们第一次经历这些。她们经历过很多次，她从不求救。当她知道我在外面什么也做不了时，尤其是在凌晨3点，那真的很严重。她总是试图不让我担心，这是……情况很严重。她不仅是害怕。她当时快死了。
It took 11 hours before he heard anything. His other sister, Heba, finally got through to Aseel. They'd survived. Heba was hiring an ambulance to try to get Aseel out. She wasn't injured. It was just the only way the family could figure out how to get to her.
过了11个小时他才收到任何消息。他的另一个姐妹Heba终于联系上了Aseel。她们幸存了。Heba雇了一辆救护车试图把Aseel接出来。她没受伤。这是家人能想到的唯一能接到她的办法。
She's moving to Gaza City?
她要搬去加沙城？
Yeah.
是的。
Well--
好吧——
[SIGHS] One second. [INAUDIBLE] So my sister Heba is texting me now saying that it was very hard to send the ambulance. And he just agreed.
（叹气）等一下。（听不清）我的姐妹Heba现在发短信说送救护车太难了。但他刚才同意了。
Hammash family group chat, Yousef to the group-- "Aseel has arrived at the girls' house." "Are you asking or telling?" Yousef-- "I'm telling you." Upside down face. "Thank God she's safe." "Thank God. May God keep them safe and well, God willing."
Hammash家庭群，Yousef对群组——“Aseel到达女孩们家了。”“你是在问还是在说？”Yousef——“我在告诉你。”（倒立表情）“感谢上帝她平安。”“感谢上帝。愿上帝保佑她们平安健康，真主保佑。”
And then, 5:51 PM, Aseel shows back up in the chat. Aseel-- "I'm fine, guys, but I'm devastated." I got a text, too. "I'm fine," she said, "but my psyche is broken." Aseel has not gone back since.
然后，下午5:51，Aseel又在聊天记录里出现了。Aseel——“我很好，伙计们，但我崩溃了。”我也收到了短信。“我很好，”她说，“但我的精神垮了。”Aseel从那以后就没再回去过。
19 months is a long time, long enough to move four times, to create a home out of nothing, to start a new business, long enough for Aseel to be pregnant, to deliver her first baby, and for that baby to learn to roll over, crawl, and walk, long enough to feel certain that this cannot possibly go on any longer. The day after this terrible night, Aseel sent me one more text-- "I'm pregnant. I don't know if I should be worried or upset or happy. I don't know what to feel."
19个月太久了，久到搬了四次家，白手起家建立一个家，开展一项新业务，久到Aseel怀了孕、生了第一个孩子，那孩子学会了翻身、爬行和走路，久到觉得这一切不可能再持续下去了。那个可怕夜晚的第二天，Aseel又给我发了一条短信——“我怀孕了。我不知道该担心、难过还是开心。我不知道该感受什么。”
When Aseel and Yousef shared their messages, I started reading from the beginning and didn't stop for hours and hours until I was finished, hundreds of pages and photos and videos later. After I was done, I kept scrolling back up to the beginning, to how the story starts, two years ago, a family planning a day at the beach.
当Aseel和Yousef分享他们的信息时，我从头读起，几个小时里一直没停，直到读完，翻了数百页的照片和视频。读完后，我不断往上翻到最初，故事是如何开始的，两年前，一家人计划去海滩。
"Make a cinnamon roll, Heba, and arrange it here." "Heba, I'm scared you'll ruin the cinnamon roll. You're good at baking cake. Bake a cake. Hadeel's cinnamon roll is tasty." "I'll make a cake, and you won't eat it." "Who told you we won't eat it?" "OK, I'll make you a cake." "Aseel, do you want to bring the nuts? Bring the seeds and nuts."
“烤个肉桂卷吧，Heba，摆在这儿。”“Heba，我怕你搞砸肉桂卷。你擅长烤蛋糕。烤个蛋糕吧。Hadeel的肉桂卷很美味。”“我要烤蛋糕，你们不吃。”“谁说的我们不吃？”“好吧，我给你们烤蛋糕。”“Aseel，你想带坚果吗？带点种子和坚果。”
Aseel-- "Shall I make you a crepe?" "No." Aseel-- "Shall I make you some pastries?" "Come on, Aseel. Manal and I will work with you. Do you know how to make a cinnamon roll?" It felt like a shock being in the presence of a family in this way and the banality of a moment. I understood, oh, this is what this family was. This is what was destroyed.
Aseel——“要我给你做个可丽饼吗？”“不。”Aseel——“要我给你做点糕点吗？”“来吧，Aseel。Manal和我帮你。你知道怎么做肉桂卷吗？”以这种方式感受一个家庭以及那个时刻的平凡，真让人震惊。我明白了，噢，这就是这个家庭曾经的样子。这就是被摧毁的东西。
Coming up, a refresher-- how many pounds are in a kilo again? 2.2 pounds-- and other memorable measurements. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，复习一下——一公斤到底有多少磅？2.2磅——以及其他值得记住的度量衡。一分钟后回到芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt, sitting in for Ira Glass. Today's show, Group Chat. We're hearing from Palestinians living outside the West Bank and Gaza, checking in with people there. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Week 11.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Chana Joffe-Walt，代替Ira Glass主持。今天的节目，群聊。我们听到的是巴勒斯坦人住在约旦河西岸和加沙之外，与那里的人保持联系。我们已经到达节目的第二幕。第二幕，第11周。
Mohammed Mhawish left Gaza a year ago, around the same time as Yousef, just before the border closed. Mohammed's a reporter. He's lived in Gaza his whole life. And he spent the last year, since he left, continuing to report and talk to people back home. Some are people he knows, others he finds through his reporting.
Mohammed Mhawish一年前离开了加沙，和Yousef大约在同一时间，就在边境关闭之前。Mohammed是名记者。他一辈子住在加沙。离开后，他花了一年时间继续报道并与家乡的人交谈。有些人是他认识的，有些是他通过报道找到的。
He's been trying to document each phase of the current war. Last fall, the messages and voice memos Mohammed was getting from people in Gaza were about evacuations or about people figuring out where to move to be safe. In November and December, the messages were about the cold. Winter was coming. Now, they've turned to food.
他一直试图记录当前战争的每个阶段。去年秋天，Mohammed从加沙人们那里收到的信息和语音备忘录是关于撤离的，或者人们在想办法搬到哪里安全。11月和12月，信息是关于寒冷的。冬天来了。现在，它们变成了食物。
Israel has imposed restrictions on food and supplies entering Gaza throughout the war. In March, they began a total blockade. No food was allowed in for 11 weeks. Israel said it was to pressure Hamas to release hostages.
以色列在整个战争期间限制食物和补给进入加沙。3月，他们开始了全面封锁。11周内不允许任何食物进入。以色列称这是为了向哈马斯施压要求释放人质。
Now, just this week, Israel is allowing a trickle of food, but it's doing so through a brand new, privately-run system that's backed by Israel and the US. This new system now has only three food distribution sites running. There used to be hundreds. A UN official has said the new system, quote, "cannot possibly meet Gaza's needs."
现在，就在这周，以色列允许少量食物进入，但它是通过一个由以色列和美国支持的全新的私人系统进行的。这个新系统目前只有三个食品分发点在运行。过去曾有几百个。一位联合国官员表示，这个新系统，“完全无法满足加沙的需求。”
The upshot, as of the moment I'm saying this, is there's still not enough food inside Gaza, especially in the north. Mohammed has been talking to people there. Here he is.
结论是，就在我说话的这一刻，加沙内部仍然缺乏食物，尤其是在北部。Mohammed一直在和那里的人交谈。他在下面。
A few weeks ago, I got a phone call from my friend, Abdelhakim Aburiash. He's in Gaza, in the north. He said, I can't explain the pain in my stomach, in my bones, in my head. I know exactly what he meant. Right before I left Gaza a year ago, I was in the north of the strip. There was a blockade then as well-- no food or supplies. My son and I were both diagnosed with acute malnutrition.
几周前，我接到了朋友Abdelhakim Aburiash的电话。他在加沙，在北部。他说，我无法解释胃里、骨头里、脑袋里的疼痛。我完全明白他的意思。一年前离开加沙前，我就在加沙北部。那时也有封锁——没有食物或补给。我和儿子都被诊断出患有严重的营养不良。
Now, it's not just the north. All of Gaza is hungry. When I call people there now, all I hear are stories of hunger, the quiet and desperate tricks that people have come up with to survive. A father living in my old neighborhood, Al Daraj, told me his family of five shared a single Snickers bar for lunch. We slice it like cake, he said. We make it a moment.
现在，不仅是北部了。整个加沙都在挨饿。当我给那里的人打电话时，听到的全是饥饿的故事，人们想出的那些安静而绝望的生存技巧。一位住在旧街区Al Daraj的父亲告诉我，他一家五口午饭分吃一条士力架。我们像切蛋糕一样切开它，他说。我们让它成为一个特别的时刻。
I talked to a son in charge of searching for food for his whole family, who told me, we boil herbs to trick our bodies into thinking we're full. We feed the children first, then wait to see if there is anything left. Most nights, there isn't.
我采访了一个负责为全家寻找食物的儿子，他说，我们煮草药来欺骗身体以为吃饱了。我们先喂孩子，然后等着看还有没有剩的。大多时候，没剩的。
Now, I'm talking a lot to another person in the north, Huda Skaik. She is 20 years old. A few months ago, she messaged me out of the blue. She said she wanted to be a journalist, asked me for advice on how to pitch to news outlets.
现在，我经常和北部的另一个人Huda Skaik聊天。她20岁。几个月前，她突然发信息给我。她说她想当记者，向我咨询如何向新闻机构投稿。
These days, I message her for updates. I called her on week 11 of the blockade, week 11 of no food going into Gaza. We don't just talk about food. She has ambitions. I asked which journalists from Gaza she'd been reading lately.
这些天，我发信息问她近况。封锁的第11周，也就是没有食物进入加沙的第11周，我给她打了电话。我们不只是谈论食物。她有抱负。我问她最近在读加沙哪些记者的文章。
So I read for Hind Khoudary, her reports. And also, I read for Ahmed Dremly, if you know him. Of course you know him.
我读了Hind Khoudary的报道。还有Ahmed Dremly的，如果你认识他的话。你当然认识他。
So you're not reading my work. OK, thank you. [LAUGHS]
所以你没读我的文章。好的，谢谢。（笑声）
No, of course. No, I swear. I swear I read for you. Sorry.
不，当然。不，我发誓。我发誓我读你的文章。抱歉。
I wrote some vocabulary, and I will send you some photos after finishing this interview to show you that I'm reading for you.
我记了一些词汇，采访结束后我会发你一些照片，证明我在读你的文章。
She did. Huda is a very serious student. She is studying English literature online through the Islamic University of Gaza-- first in her class. She told me studying brings her peace. It was nighttime in Gaza when we talked, nine hours since she'd last eaten.
她发了。Huda是个非常认真的学生。她正在通过加沙伊斯兰大学在线攻读英语文学——成绩全班第一。她说学习给她带来平静。我们交谈时加沙是晚上，她已经九个小时没吃东西了。
And I brought a bottle of water here, next to me. Every time I feel hungry, I drink some. And then I feel like, oh, I'm full. And I'm intending to drink a lot of water in the coming days in order to stay alive. This is the only way my stomach will be full a little bit. This is how I make myself patient with hungry.
我这儿带了一瓶水，就在身边。每当我感到饿，就喝一点。然后我感觉，噢，我饱了。我打算在接下来的几天里多喝水，为了活下去。这是我让胃部稍微饱胀的唯一方法。这就是我让自己忍受饥饿的方式。
It's exam time right now. Huda has been putting her headphones on and studying late into the night. I was astonished by Huda's ability to stay focused. Night time is terrifying in Gaza. All we could hear was explosions and the sound of drones getting closer. But Huda just studies through it.
现在是考试时间。Huda戴上耳机学习到深夜。我对Huda保持专注的能力感到惊讶。加沙的夜晚令人恐惧。我们只能听到爆炸声和无人机靠近的声音。但Huda就在这声音中学习。
So when all of my siblings and my parents are falling asleep, I study. So when I get hungry, sometimes at night, you know what I do? I go to the kitchen, and I eat a spoon of za'atar. So we have a jar of za'atar, OK? So in order to not make my mom notice that I am eating from it, I go to the kitchen. And I--
当我的兄弟姐妹和父母睡着时，我就学习。所以当我感到饿时，有时在晚上，你知道我做什么吗？我去厨房，吃一勺za'atar。我们有一罐za'atar，好吗？为了不让妈妈发现我在吃它，我去了厨房。我——
So you sneak a bite in silence--
所以你静静地偷吃一口——
Yes.
是的。
--so that no one--
——这样没人——
Exactly. Exactly. Thank God that my parents don't know English. OK.
正是。正是。感谢上帝我父母不懂英语。好吧。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And sometimes I feel like I am guilty because it's for my siblings in the morning, and oh, my God. But I want to satisfy my hunger. And I'm studying, and I want to focus.
有时我感到内疚，因为那是留给兄弟姐妹早上吃的，噢，天哪。但我想满足饥饿感。而且我在学习，我想专注。
Yeah.
是啊。
And then after eating those two spoons, I drink one or two cups of water in order to feel like I had a dinner. I yearn for eating some cheese.
吃完那两勺，我就喝一两杯水，让自己感觉像是吃了晚饭。我渴望吃点奶酪。
Before the war, Huda was the kind of person who liked to take pictures of what she was eating, especially when she made it. These days, when she gets hungry, she scrolls through those pictures. She said it helps her feel full, just looking at them. She told me about a photo of maqluba from 2022, a screenshot of a burger ad. She told me she zooms in and pretends she's picking the crispy bits off the chicken.
战争前，Huda是那种喜欢拍下食物照片的人，尤其是她自己做的时候。这些天，当她饿的时候，她会翻看那些照片。她说看着它们能帮她感觉饱了。她告诉我2022年的一张maqluba照片，还有一张汉堡广告的截图。她说她放大照片，假装自己正把鸡肉上酥脆的部分挑出来。
I wanted to have an idea if you've ever been to the market lately and what kinds of things that are still being sold.
我想了解一下，你最近有没有去过市场，还有哪些种类的东西还在出售。
OK, so most of the market shelves are really scarce and are empty. You can see some canned food or even lentils, rice, soup, pasta. These are the items that are currently available, but in a very, very, very expensive prices.
市场货架真的很少，都空了。你能看到一些罐头食品，甚至扁豆、大米、汤、意大利面。这些是目前有的商品，但价格非常非常非常贵。
Like almost $11 for a candy bar. A year ago, prices were high, but not this high. People still had stored food. There were still some farms. The market I used to shop at still had stock.
就像一根糖条快要11美元了。一年前，价格很高，但没这么高。人们还存有食物。还有一些农场。我以前购物的市场还有存货。
There were snacks, and there was green leaves, some vegetables, some green vegetables. Yeah.
有零食，有绿叶菜，一些蔬菜，一些绿色蔬菜。是啊。
That are not available now. I hope they was available so I can make myself busy with them while studying. And--
现在没有了。我希望它们还在，这样我在学习时就能忙于处理它们。而且——
There was also-- there was also some coffee. There was also some tea. There was some sugar that we would use sometimes. We can sweeten some water with sugar, and we can drink. And so it could have some sort of a feeling of a sweet thing that could be enough for the body to feel full at some point somehow. Sugar, is it available? How much does it cost to get 1 kilo of sugar?
还有……还有一些咖啡。还有一些茶。有一些糖我们有时会用。我们可以用糖让水变甜，我们可以喝。这样它就能有一种甜味的感觉，在某种程度上足以让身体感到饱足。糖，有卖吗？1公斤糖要多少钱？
Let me ask my brother. How does it cost? $30, 1 kilo.
让我问问我哥哥。要多少钱？30美元，1公斤。
$30 for 1 kilo?
1公斤30美元？
Yeah.
是的。
Oh, my God.
噢，天哪。
A kilo is a little over 2 pounds. Before the war, a kilo of sugar cost about $0.25, $0.30 on the high end. When I was still in Gaza, a kilo of sugar was already outrageous, $16. And it was already hard to find.
1公斤稍微多于2磅。战争前，1公斤糖大约要0.25美元，高档的也就是0.30美元。我还在加沙时，1公斤糖已经离谱到16美元了。而且已经很难买到了。
Now there is almost nothing. Farmland has been wiped out, greenhouses turned to ash. It's not just the food that's gone. There is no fuel to cook what little might be left-- rice, lentils. There is no fuel to even boil water.
现在几乎什么都没有了。农田被摧毁，温室化为灰烬。消失的不仅是食物。没有燃料煮剩下的那点米、扁豆。甚至没有燃料烧开水。
There isn't any burning wood around you, right?
你周围没有木柴了吧，对吗？
Yeah. There is no wood right now. We sometimes bought some plastics, you know? Or nylon or whatever we find in the street in order to fuel the fire.
是的。现在没木头了。我们有时买些塑料，你知道吗？或者尼龙，或者我们在街上发现的任何东西来点火。
Yeah.
是啊。
When I study, I have my notebooks, which are really close to my heart. And I can't let them burn with--
我学习时，有笔记本，它们离我的心很近。我不能让它们烧掉——
Give them up. Yeah.
放弃它们吧。是啊。
Yeah. But I have another papers. These are for my mom when she burns the-- for the food.
是啊。但我有别的纸。这些是我妈用来烧火的——做饭用的。
When she cooks. Yeah.
她做饭时。是啊。
When she cooks. She's burnt some of our clothes. And it's something like you-- when we burn these things, I feel like we are burning some of our memories, a huge number, a huge amount of our memories.
她做饭时。她烧了一些我们的衣服。就像你……当我们烧这些东西时，我觉得我们在烧掉我们的记忆，大量的记忆。
I dreamed of my cousin that was killed in the first beginning of the war, just two days ago. She was telling me that she was missing me and that she wants me to eat some food. She tells me that she feels like I am hungry.
两天前，我梦到了我在战争初期遇难的堂姐。她告诉我她想我，想让我吃点食物。她告诉我她感觉我饿了。
She was cooking for me something that I love, which is the basta, but in a very delicious way. She made it in the dream. And then when I woke up, I felt like I am full. I felt like I don't want to eat, you know? It's really something indescribable. And I felt so sad when I saw her.
她在梦里为我煮了我喜欢的东西，是basta，非常美味。她在梦里做好了。醒来时，我觉得我饱了。我觉得我不想吃东西，你知道吗？这真的是无法形容。看到她时我感到很伤心。
I'm sorry. I'm so sorry for your loss. I'm so sorry.
我很遗憾。我为你的损失感到非常遗憾。非常抱歉。
Yeah. I started telling my friends that pray to have a dream like this, you know? It's really so bad. Oh. Oh, my God.
是啊。我开始告诉朋友祈祷能做这样的梦，你知道吗？真的很糟糕。噢。噢，天哪。
I remember the way hunger settled into my body. Not just as pain, but as a kind of silence. When I stood up, the room spun. My mouth tasted like metal. My limbs felt heavy, like I was wading through water. I stopped feeling hunger as a craving. It became something else, a slow shutting down.
我记得饥饿感在体内的感觉。不只是作为疼痛，而是一种沉默。当我站起来，房间在转。嘴里有金属味。四肢沉重，好像我在水里涉行。我不再把饥饿感视为一种渴望。它变成了别的，一种缓慢的停滞。
I have never, ever expected to reach to such level, to seek food, to think of food, to only just want to-- I just want to eat food. And I feel like people are going insane. We could lose our minds if we didn't have food immediately.
我从没、从没想过会达到这种程度，去寻找食物，去思考食物，去只想——我只是想吃点食物。我觉得人们要疯了。如果我们不立刻吃东西，我们就会失去理智。
When I first talked to Huda, I could tell she was ambitious. She talked about wanting to be a teacher. She dreamt of getting her master's degree abroad. But just before we talked, she had started to rethink that plan because she doesn't want to leave Gaza behind.
刚和Huda交谈时，我看得出她很有抱负。她谈到想当老师。她梦想去国外读硕士。但在我们交谈前，她开始重新考虑那个计划，因为她不想把加沙抛在身后。
The Israelis are trying to erase all the traces of Palestinians and uprooted them. And they are trying to put the idea of traveling and to get out of Gaza. But we will not. We will always stay in our homes. And sometimes, I feel like how does the world outside Gaza feel? How is the world behind the Rafah crossing? How did you feel when you get on a plane? Can you tell me?
以色列人试图抹去巴勒斯坦人的所有痕迹，把他们连根拔起。他们试图植入旅行和离开加沙的想法。但我们不会离开。我们将永远留在我们的家中。有时，我觉得加沙之外的世界是什么感受？Rafah过境点背后的世界怎么样？当你登上飞机时是什么感受？你能告诉我吗？
[BREATHES DEEPLY]
（深呼吸）
I was surprised by Huda's question, and I had trouble answering it. It slammed me back to the moment as I was crossing into Egypt-- no drones, no sounds of war. People were just living, only 30 minutes away from Gaza, sipping sodas, grilling on the street, kids heading to school, others coming back from college.
我对Huda的问题感到惊讶，我很难回答。这让我猛然回到跨入埃及的那一刻——没有无人机，没有战争的声音。人们就在那里生活，离加沙只有30分钟路程，啜饮汽水，在街上烧烤，孩子们上学，另一些人大学回来。
The world outside Gaza, it's an overwhelming mix of things. My mouth isn't capable of what it wants to speak. I think it's good for us to be in other parts of the world to share what is happening back home. But to do that, I had to leave everything behind, knowing I may never go back. My home is out of reach. This is kind of breaking my heart.
加沙之外的世界，是各种事物的交织，让人应接不暇。我的嘴无法说出它想说的话。我认为我们出现在世界其他地方分享家乡发生的事情是件好事。但为了做到这一点，我必须抛下一切，知道我可能永远回不去了。我的家遥不可及。这真让我心碎。
Huda texted me after our call and surprised me with another question. She asked what I had for breakfast. I lied. I said, coffee and toast. These two things are still available somewhere in Gaza. I did not tell her I had one egg, a cookie, and a cup of tea.
通话结束后，Huda给我发了条短信，另一个问题让我惊讶。她问我早餐吃了什么。我撒谎了。我说，咖啡和吐司。这两样东西在加沙的某些地方还能买到。我没告诉她我吃了一个鸡蛋、一块饼干和一杯茶。
Mohammed Mhawish is a journalist and writer from Gaza. Diane Wu produced this story. You can find more of Mohammed's reporting in Al Jazeera and MSNBC. He's also a contributing writer for The Nation, which is where we first read about his experiences with hunger. Huda's access to food has not changed since Mohammed spoke with her two weeks ago.
Mohammed Mhawish是来自加沙的记者和作家。Diane Wu制作了这个故事。你可以在半岛电视台和MSNBC找到Mohammed的更多报道。他也是《国家》杂志的撰稿人，我们在那里首次读到了他关于饥饿的经历。自Mohammed两周前与她交谈以来，Huda获取食物的情况没有改变。
One last thing before we end today's show, almost every day, someone asks me about a kid we put on the show six months ago, Banias. She's in Gaza. The thing people always want to know-- how is she doing? This is a question I find very difficult to answer. But here we go. I'm going to try.
今天结束节目之前最后一点，几乎每天，都有人问我关于我们六个月前节目里的一个孩子，Banias。她在加沙。人们总是想知道的一件事——她怎么样了？这个问题我发现很难回答。但我们要开始了。我会试一下。
Banias is still in Central Gaza, where she's been displaced from the north. She turned nine during the ceasefire, in January. She's living in an apartment with a yard. There are long stretches when she can't go outside, when it's not safe enough. When she can go out, there are kids nearby she plays with. She draws. She pretends to be a naturalist. Banias loves bugs. She does remote school for a few hours each week. She's skinnier.
Banias仍然在加沙中部，她从北部流离失所到这里。她在停火期间，也就是1月，过了九岁生日。她住在一套带院子的公寓里。有很长一段时间她不能出去，不够安全。当她能出去时，附近有孩子和她玩。她画画。她假装是博物学家。Banias喜欢虫子。她每周远程上几个小时的学。她变瘦了。
Banias's family has far more resources than most people in Gaza. But still, her parents spend most of the day trying to find food lately or waiting in lines to access an oven, where they can cook bread if they have flour. Most days, they don't. They eat lentils and rice or lentils and pasta. They're running out of canned food. Her mom told me, on a good day, they'll also share one fried potato for the family of four.
Banias的家人比加沙大多数人有更多的资源。但即便如此，她的父母大部分时间都在尝试寻找食物，或者排队等候使用烤箱，如果有面粉的话可以烤面包。大多数日子里，他们不吃。他们吃扁豆和大米，或者是扁豆和意大利面。他们的罐头食品快吃完了。她妈妈告诉我，在情况好的日子里，他们还会为这一家四口分吃一个炸土豆。
How is Banias doing should be a really simple question. Banias is wonderful. She's charming, endlessly curious, and energetic, and bursting with things to say. She's very funny. And Banias is still incredibly good at creating her own reality.
Banias怎么样是一个非常简单的问题。Banias很棒。她迷人、充满好奇心、精力充沛，充满了想说的话。她很有趣。而且Banias仍然极其擅长创造她自己的现实。
I'm so happy today. I'm really, really, really happy.
我今天很高兴。我真的、真的、真的很高兴。
Yeah? Why?
是吗？为什么？
The kids are playing in the backyard, and I'm sitting here in the balcony.
孩子们在后院玩，我坐在阳台上。
Uh-huh.
嗯。
There is our clothes.
那里有我们的衣服。
Uh-huh.
嗯。
Sometimes it was loud bombing around us. That's sometimes.
有时周围有巨大的轰炸声。那只是有时。
[DISTANT EXPLOSION]
[远处爆炸声]
Oh, here's one.
噢，有一个。
Yeah, I just heard it.
是啊，我刚听到了。
It's not close of us. This is a lemon tree. I want to show you an olive tree we like to climb. This olive tree is so easy to climb. I just step-- uh-oh, I was about to fall. OK, I'll switch the camera to show you. I'll hold the phone tightly. And you step--
离我们不近。这是一棵柠檬树。我想给你看一棵我们喜欢爬的橄榄树。这棵橄榄树爬起来很容易。我只要踩——噢噢，我差点摔倒。好吧，我切换镜头给你看。我会握紧手机。然后你踩——
[LAUGHS] Are you climbing the tree right now?
[笑] 你现在在爬树吗？
And I'm-- and I'm climbing. Look, this is the olive tree. And look! I'm here, I'm here. Here am I. Woo-hoo! I'm the king of the garden!
我在——我在爬。看，这是橄榄树。看！我在上面，我在上面。我在那儿。呜呼！我是花园女王！
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
I'm the queen of the garden!
我是花园的女王！
Oh, Banias, is it safe there?
噢，Banias，那里安全吗？
It is safe. Don't worry about us. But there's some shooting around us.
是安全的。别担心我们。但周围有一些枪声。
Yeah, I can hear it.
是啊，我听到了。
So don't go to high places. I'll just get down--
所以别去高处。我下去——
Yeah, maybe come down.
是啊，也许下来吧。
--so I doesn't get shooted. [GRUNTING]
——这样我就不会被射中了。（咕哝声）
Yeah.
是啊。
So cool.
太酷了。
Maybe you should go back inside.
也许你应该回到里面去。
No, it's OK. It's far away from us.
不，没关系。离我们很远。
It sounds close.
听起来很近。
If you're scared, we can, ba-ha, we can go inside.
如果你害怕，我们能，巴哈，我们可以进去。
Yeah. Why don't we go inside?
是啊。为什么我们不进去？
You want to go inside?
你想进去？
Yeah.
是啊。
All right, let's go. [LAUGHS]
好吧，我们走吧。[笑]
[SIGHS]
[叹气]
That's how Banias is doing, fiercely protecting and inventing a childhood for herself, a childhood that is constrained in every way by shooting and bombing, by a lack of nutrition, education, and safety. That's how she's doing.
Banias就是这样生活的，拼命保护并为自己创造一个童年，一个被枪声和轰炸、被营养匮乏、教育和安全缺失所束缚的童年。这就是她现在的样子。
Our show today was produced by Lilly Sullivan. Nancy Updike edited the show. The people who put our show together include Michael Comite, Angela Gervasi, Ira Glass, Cassie Howley, Valerie Kipnis, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Anthony Roman, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, and Marisa Robertson-Textor.
我们今天的节目由Lilly Sullivan制作。Nancy Updike编辑。参与我们节目制作的还有Michael Comite、Angela Gervasi、Ira Glass、Cassie Howley、Valerie Kipnis、Seth Lind、Miki Meek、Katherine Rae Mondo、Stowe Nelson、Nadia Reiman、Anthony Roman、Alissa Shipp、Christopher Swetala和Marisa Robertson-Textor。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Emanuele Berry is our executive editor. Special thanks today to Hany Hawasly, Laura Albast, Rania Mustafa, Dana Ballout, Rachel Strom, Emna Zygal, Lizzy Ratner, and Suzanne Gaber. Thanks also to KCRW in Los Angeles, where I've been recording this week and have had help from Katie Gilchrest, Phil Richards, Mike Stark, and Mike Newport. Voiceover for Aseel in Act One was performed by Tara Aboud.
我们的主编是Sarah Abdurrahman。高级编辑是David Kestenbaum。Emanuele Berry是我们的执行编辑。特别感谢今天的Hany Hawasly、Laura Albast、Rania Mustafa、Dana Ballout、Rachel Strom、Emna Zygal、Lizzy Ratner和Suzanne Gaber。也感谢洛杉矶的KCRW电台，我这周在那里录制，得到了Katie Gilchrest、Phil Richards、Mike Stark和Mike Newport的帮助。第一幕Aseel的配音由Tara Aboud担任。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. If you become a This American Life Partner, you'll get bonus content, ad-free listening, and more. To join, go to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. That link is also in the show notes. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt. Ira Glass will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。如果你成为《美国生活》的合作伙伴，你将获得额外内容、无广告收听等福利。加入请访问thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。该链接也在节目说明中。《美国生活》由公共广播电台交流中心PRX分发至公共广播电台。我是Chana Joffe-Walt。Ira Glass下周将带着《美国生活》的更多故事回来。